he added uh or he said yesterday that
that one of his former places to play
the baltimore ravens is a tough place to
be a receiver
said smith i'm a wide receiver and my
question is always going to be how is
this passing game going to develop i
hate to say it this way but as a wide
receiver i loved the block but i didn't
wake up trying to block and run 70 plays
a game and 68 of the 70 or run plays
because
then when the contract season comes up
you have leverage because my numbers
aren't up and you know there's something
to be said there you want to inherit the
these statistics if you are a pass
catcher nobody is paying
run blocking wide receivers they want
guys who can produce in the passing game
and if your offense isn't conducive to
production you have a problem remember
last year when they were devising this
lamar jackson run-based offense how
difficult it was for the ravens to find
free agents they had to draft marquis
brown and the guy from notre dame help
me out who together miles boycott
draft receivers again this year
you're not going to get guys to choose
to sign on when they have options
because they understand that the
statistics aren't going to be the same
they're not going to we know every
receiver wants to run routes and catch
passes score touchdowns that's what they
want to do
you're getting them to go against their
nature as part of this ravens offense to
a certain extent chris
yeah you definitely are i mean it's
going to be hard to be a receiver in
this baltimore ravens offense and then
you know put forth uh a resume of
hall of fame material as far as catches
and touchdowns and everything like that
yeah it could be hard now do we we saw a
big drastic improvement in their pass
game last year and i think that will
continue we've heard lamar jackson this
offseason talk about he doesn't think
he'll be running as much this year as he
was last year no
we're here last year but at some point
it's going to have to calm down a little
bit you know it just it's playing with
fire he's going to get worn out i don't
know if you can continue to do that but
it's a very real aspect steve smith
brings up you know hey the baltimore
ravens ran the ball almost 100 times
more than the next team in football
which was the 49ers you know so yes
i think you kind of hit on it mike when
it comes to the ravens with the wide
receiver position hey offensive lineman
you know defensive front seven anybody
on defense is going to want to come to
baltimore tight ends and running backs
you're gonna want to come to baltimore
receivers are once as one spot then
they're gonna go man it looks cool and
i'd love to play lamar jackson and they
win games and it's fun but damn i might
get done with the year and only have
like three catches a game and that's
where i think to what you said it's
gonna have to be through the draft and i
think you'll continue to see that them
draft one or two receivers every year
because they know they're not going to
get big-time free agents to come there
and want to play for that offense
but you know as defenses continue to
come up with ways to slow down that
run-based offense maybe it does open up
opportunities to throw right lamar
jackson develops as a pass so the game
slows down more he gets a better
understanding of the pre-snap looks
the natural progression of a quarterback
the more you step up to the line of
scrimmage the more you survey the
defense the more you process what you
see before the snap what you see at the
snap how the players move where the
openings are going to be the patterns
that develop that that uh that does
create opportunities for a great passing
offense but you know here's the thing
and i think it was kyle shanahan that
explained this last year and i'm clearly
paraphrasing here because i haven't
thought of this in months but basically
you know you
you you can't simulate lamar jackson you
can't stand for lamar jackson whatever
you think is gonna work goes out the
window because ultimately you have to go
catch him and at this point in the nfl
he's the hardest guy for any defensive
player to track down even when you know
what he's going to do chris well he he
is it's it's just like when i was
playing for the tampa bay buccaneers and
we had to play the atlanta falcons and
michael vick you know it just it didn't
matter yeah i could i could maybe throw
like michael vick but i couldn't run
like him and then you know you would get
a receiver or a db in there to run like
michael vick but then they could throw
worth the damn in practice or whatever
it may be you can't prepare yourself to
play a guy like amar jackson because
he's in the conversation for one of the
quickest people in football in space and
really one of the faster straight ahead
speed uh people as far as a ball carrier
is concerned too but you know hey let's
not forget lamar jackson threw for 36
touchdown passes last year and led the
nfl so while the yards might not be all
that great for receivers and things like
that you certainly could have a chance
to have a lot of easy touchdowns and
have that bolster your staff package to
where you can ask for big time money uh
when it does come for a free agent
contract or something like that
tight end is the key mark andrews had 98
targets last year for the right marquis
brown was the top receiver with 71
targets that was 60th among all nfl
receivers but still as this offense
grows and develops as lamar jackson
grows and develops there could be more
opportunities in the passing game and
some of these rookies who are growing
and developing may not have to leave via
free agency they may get paid right
where they are
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports